yo voy a seguir hablando de algo que en
realidad alguien introdujo muy bien en
una charla anterior que fue el
ilusionista pedro y hablaba de cómo la
ciencia de alguna manera se relaciona
con los sueños yo también os voy a
hablar de los sueños de lo de la
potencia y de la fuerza que tienen los
sueños y lo va a hacer empezando
pues con un cuento con una historia la
historia de una niña
una niña pequeña que tenía un padre
científico muy inteligente una persona
reconocida a nivel mundial pero que
dedicaba mucho tiempo cuando la costaba
de su niña pues a contarle cuentos y
ayudar a fomentar esa creatividad que
tienen los niños esa manera de pensar
esa manera dejar volar la imaginación la
niña fue creciendo y el padre siguió
contando la historias pero según se
hacía mayor pues a veces le contaba
historias que además eran realidad y un
día le contó una historia que marcaría
su vida más de lo que incluso programar
probablemente el padre se imaginaba y es
que le habló de la probabilidad que toda
materia tenía de convertirse en onda
como la luz o como el sonido o como las
ondas se podían convertir en materia y
eso le hizo soñar aún mucho más allá de
todo lo que había soñado esa niña con
todos esos cuentos
es más ese cuento esa historia fue la
que marcó su carrera profesional para
decidir estudiar la carrera de químicas
es una pena que la mayoría de nosotros
según nos hacemos mayores la madurez el
raciocinio quizás también el
materialismo y el capitalismo en el que
vivimos van mermando esa capacidad de
soñar que tienen los niños esa niña del
cuento tuvo más suerte tuvo más suerte
gracias a su padre que hizo que siguiera
soñando aún a pesar de seguir creciendo
esa niña
estudió la carrera vio que existía
muchísimo conocimiento más allá del que
se pudiera imaginar y fue cuando llegó
al último año de carrera que se dio
cuenta de que seguían existiendo en
mundos fascinantes que explorar y en los
que seguir soñando
uno de esos mundos es la nanotecnología
y que es la nanotecnología la
nanotecnología no es más que tecnología
a escala nanométrica es decir 10 elevado
a menos 9 metros
0,000 0000 1 metro
es decir escala pequeñísima y por sí a
16 capaces de visualizarlo con todos los
ceros que acabo de decir imaginaros que
la diferencia del tamaño que hay entre
el sol
y el hombre es la misma diferencia de
tamaño que hay entre el hombre y un
nanómetro así de pequeña es la
nanotecnología y os preguntaréis valen
muy pequeña y que es tan especial de que
sea tan pequeña pues en realidad mucho
en realidad es el tamaño lo que hace tan
interesante la nanotecnología y por qué
porque cuando disminuye es mucho el
tamaño de los materiales se incrementa
la reactividad
y ahora diréis qué es eso de la
reactividad lo voy a explicar de manera
muy sencilla imaginaros que queremos
pintar una habitación vamos a tener una
niña y vamos a pintar la habitación de
color rosa
cogemos nuestra pintura blanca y le
añadimos pigmento rosa y entonces el
pigmento rosa interactúa reacciona con
la pintura se convierte en una pintura
rosa
imaginaros que además lo hemos pintado y
ahora la queremos hacer pues más intensa
que hacemos incrementamos la
concentración de pigmento metemos más
pigmento rosa y se hace aún más rosa
pero ahora imaginaros lo siguiente que
cada uno de estos pigmentos que estamos
metiendo en el bote de pintura es un
cubo cada pigmento es un cubo
qué ocurre que en realidad lo que está
reaccionando con el medio lo que está
convirtiendo esa pintura blanca en
pintura rosa es solo la superficie del
cubo y no lo que hay dentro del cubo es
decir que los materiales están muy
desaprovechados todo lo que hay dentro
no se aprovecha ahora imaginaros que
dividimos ese cubo en un millón de cubos
lo que estamos haciendo es incrementar
la reactividad de esas partículas
incrementando el área superficial
entonces con muy poquita cantidad de
algo se consigue un efecto sorprendente
no sólo eso sino que además esas escalas
tan pequeñas en los materiales aparecen
nuevas propiedades propiedades que a
escala macroscópica no somos capaces de
ver y os pondré algunos ejemplos muy
sencillos todos conocemos el oro o la
plata bueno pues el oro cuando él se ve
cuando se trabaja con él a escala
nanométrica se vuelve magnético
la plata que también conocemos muy bien
cuando se trabaja a escala nanométrica
se vuelve fluorescente imaginaros son
sólo dos ejemplos pero imaginaros la
cantidad de propiedades que podemos
sacar de materiales que creíamos que
conocíamos bien pero que en realidad
queda mucho por descubrir solo variando
el tamaño
no sólo eso sino que además se puede ir
más allá y trabajar con partículas
nanométricas es decir partículas por
debajo de un nanómetro 0,1 metro y
cuando seguimos bajando el tamaño aún
más aún más sorprendentes son los
efectos que nos podemos encontrar aquí
en galicia hay una empresa de
nanotecnología nanogap que trabaja con
estos nanomateriales y con partículas
también psuv nanométricas y se trabaja
con proyectos absolutamente disruptivos
yo hoy os voy a poner aquí dos ejemplos
de para que se pueden utilizar estas
partículas nanométricas y sólo son dos
ejemplos porque hay que limitar el
tiempo de la charla pero hay muchísimas
cosas que se pueden hacer uno de ellos
de los que os voy a hablar es algo que
podría tener además una
la importancia en la salud de las
personas es muy importante y es el cómo
acceden los medicamentos al cuerpo
humano el cuerpo humano tiene muchas
barreras biológicas mucho más en el
cerebro el cerebro está protegido por la
barrera hematoencefálica que supone una
barrera muy fuerte que pues sí hay que
acceder al cerebro pues por un tumor
cerebral o por cualquier otra enfermedad
pues requiere de una cirugía que es lo
que se conseguiría con estas partículas
tan tan tan tan pequeñas incluso
llegarían a poder atravesar las barreras
tan fuertes como es la barrera
hematoencefálica y habría tratamientos
tan sencillos como utilizar pues el
típico gotero que tenemos para los oídos
para hacer tratamientos en el cerebro
ese es uno de los ejemplos otro de los
ejemplos de proyectos disruptivos en los
que se está trabajando y este me encanta
es el coche infinito esto lo he llamado
así de david boceta un asesor científico
que tenemos en la compañía muy bueno y
es un concepto que está muy bien que es
el coche infinito pues sí si el coche
infinito es que se puede mover
infinitamente y cómo podríamos tener un
coche híbrido
que se movería por un lado por la
producción de hidrógeno y por otro lado
como coche eléctrico por un lado que
tendríamos que con la luz solar y estas
partículas nanométricas y agua
contaminada si agua contaminada eso lo
que haría es que tenemos el sol tenemos
el agua contaminada
echamos nuestras partículas mágicas y
que ocurre que lo que haríamos es
eliminar esos contaminantes pero a la
vez que eliminamos el contaminante
producimos el hidrógeno producción que
nos puede valer como fuente de energía
para el coche y diréis bueno eso está
fenomenal pero por la noche que no hay
sol a ver qué hacemos bueno pues durante
el día lo que además tenemos sería unas
nano baterías que van almacenando un
voltaje suficiente como para que por la
noche cuando el coche nos trabajo la luz
siga moviéndose y este es uno de los
conceptos de coche infinito que en el
que se está trabajando en la empresa
para acabar os voy a
mi objetivo con esta charla es que
podáis dimensionar el potencial que
tiene la nanotecnología lo cual no es
tarea fácil todos estaréis
familiarizados más o menos yo creo con
la tabla periódica esto que tengo aquí
detrás si no sonará pues de haberlo
visto que es la tabla periódica la tabla
periódica no es más que una especie de
abecedario de la química es decir igual
que nosotros tenemos el abecedario para
formar palabras el abc de cogemos la h
cogemos la o cogemos la l cogemos la ola
de esa misma manera con la tabla
periódica recogemos todos los elementos
básicos que combinados formamos pues
todas las moléculas que forman nuestros
materiales pues por ejemplo cogemos dos
hidrógenos cogemos nuestro el gen o h2o
tenemos agua que ocurre que hasta ahora
sólo veíamos la tabla periódica desde
arriba sólo veíamos eso no veíamos nada
más qué pasa qué ocurre si empiezas a
mirar en la tabla periódica por debajo
en una tercera dimensión de la que no
éramos conscientes y que en cada uno de
esos materiales definidos en la tabla
periódica según el tamaño obtienes
propiedades totales
distintas hasta ahora lo que teníamos
era la punta del iceberg todo lo que hay
debajo es nanotecnología
es muy importante y vinculaba el
principio esto con la exposición que
hizo ilusionista porque creo que es muy
real lo que decía y es que en la ciencia
en general la capacidad de soñar es
imprescindible es imprescindible porque
necesitas tener visiones para luego
poder hacer esos sueños realidad y la
nanotecnología es un mundo con muchísimo
espacio para soñar y además con
muchísimos sueños que hace realidad
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]